hugh jackman puts his six-pack on full  display and it is hot thank you the  wolverine star was spotted at Bondi  Beach in Sydney Australia on Thursday  working out with his personal trainer  and taking an early-morning dip in the  ocean the 48 year old actor was  photographed in all his shirtless  glories this is kind of really amazing  monitor flexing his killer abs in a pair  of Navy swim trunks as he rinsed off  under the outdoor shower is it just us  or has water never looked this good I  think there's a compliment unless you're  later the hunky star met up with his  wife Deborah Lee furnace posting this  sandy selfie with the caption me and my  Beach babe and while we are practically  drooling over Hughes chiseled physique  the a-list star told et that his leading  lady thinks he's hot for a different  reason she always says that my sexy  thing about him is that he came trained  he takes the garbage  [Music]  you